welcome to PFT ot on Yahoo Sports big
questions and topics and issues in the
National Football League he's Peter King
on Mike Florio and one of the big
questions is which team in the none of
the above NFC East will actually win the
crown look Washington and the Giants
forget about them it's coming down to
the Cowboys and the Eagles it seems like
neither one wants to win the division
seems like neither one wants to win a
game who do you think between the two
Peter emerges as the champion with that
guaranteed home playoff game that goes
along with it I'll take the Philadelphia
Eagles I mean any team that has the New
York Giants twice in Washington once
even though they still probably would
have to win at Dallas I could see the
Eagles running the table as many
problems as they have right now Mike and
that games actually Philadelphia Dallas
won round one a little this year at home
good week 16 at Philly and look I here's
the thing that bothers me about the
Eagles they played a Dolphins team on
Sunday that had absolutely nothing to
play for the Eagles have everything to
play for
the door was open for them to tie the
Cowboys atop the NFC East with four
games left and the Eagles could not win
that game I think it will come down to
week 16 at Philly and I think the
Cowboys will win that game and the
Cowboys will win the division and the
Cowboys will be dangerous especially
because the Cowboys if they lock it up
week 16 can rest their starters week 17
and they will be hosting a potentially
bruised and battered loser of the 49ers
Seahawks matchup on the final Sunday of
the season where the winner is going to
be the one seat of the two-seed and the
loser is going to have to go on the road
and the Cowboys have the talent to win
in the postseason we saw them win a home
game last year they beat the Seahawks in
the wild-card round before losing to the
Rams in LA I think that the Cowboys win
the division
I think the Cowboys may win a wild card
game and Jason Garrett's coaching career
will come down to whether or not he can
win on the road at Green Bay or New
Orleans or
San Francisco or Seattle and he probably
won't and it will probably mean the
Cowboys will be looking for a new head
coach Peter under your scenario Mike
isn't it
doesn't it just strike you as being just
tremendously unfair if the Cowboys do
have it clinched entering week 17 isn't
it ridiculous that that the 49ers in
Seahawks by the way there's a good
chance on Sunday night the 49ers and
Seahawks are gonna beat the living tar
out of each other and then one of those
two teams gonna have to get in a plane
and go 1,900 miles you know on Friday or
the next week it's just man I don't know
I I don't want to I don't want to be a
crier about the NFC West but this whole
process just there's something about it
that smells well there's not enough
teams in the divisions right it's it's a
perfect structure it's very symmetrical
it looks great on paper you've got four
divisions per conference four teams per
division but being the best of four
teams that should not guarantee a home
game in today's NFL right I mean before
they did the realignment there were five
teams in every division you have five
teams in every division then yeah you
win the division you get a home game
remember Peter before they did the
realignment in 2002 the the fourth seed
wasn't a Division champion and still got
a home game in the playoff so as you
said during pft live on Wednesday just
because that's the way they're doing it
doesn't mean they can't change it and
maybe it takes a ridiculously extreme
example where we are robbed of a quality
team like the 49ers of the Seahawks
because they have to go to Dallas and
they lose to a Cowboys team that was
able to coast into week 17 rest the
starters set the tej of the stage to win
the game maybe that's something that'll
spark change and and I I don't know why
anybody would be against that why would
you want to punish a team that goes
thirteen and three twelve and four and
forced them to go play an eight and a
team in their own building it's unfair
but nobody seems to care
except us it's a very simple reason why
people won't change it because those
teams are going to get their ox gored
they're gonna get the division winner is
going to get a home game robbed and I I
don't care
the owners care all right more PFT ot
videos throughout the course of the
season we'll see in here next time
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports